so let's let's talk about
two things one it sounds like the
comparison operator the equality
operator
is the thing that you regret so maybe
making it sloppy making it sloppy so
what is the biggest
thing you regret in those 10 days and
what is the biggest thing you're proud
of
so that that making it sloppy came after
the 10 days and my lesson there which
i've tweeted is
when people come to you saying can you
please make it sloppy add this cute
feature
the answer should be no and i should
have known that because i think
nicolas veret one of my heroes said the
essence of design is leaving things out
um but during the 10 days i also like i
said i was in such a hurry i left out
garbage collection
came back to haunt me but i got
reference counting in in time that
people
uh weren't running out of memory right
away on on long-lived jobs
what happens when you don't have garbage
collection you have objects well you
just run out of memory
and you know i love it at first you
write a short script and the page
doesn't last long or it doesn't do a lot
and it's okay oh i see yeah yeah but if
you're writing a game or something and
you're
doing event based allocation you run out
of memory and this was noticed
in the summer of 1995 and people were
like what's going on oh yeah i gotta get
i
better go back and do reference counting
and then the problem with reference
counting is you're writing the language
in the runtime in c an unsafe language
and if you're reference counting and you
overflow the counter you mismanage it so
it goes high it gets stuck high you leak
memory again and you run out
if you underflow it you pre-memory
that's still in use
and even then we knew what all the
security hackers
came to know that you therefore have a
potentially a remote
code execution vulnerability because
this is before things like
non-executable heap memory and
stack defenses against taking over
memory so if you can
from the the remote side write some html
javascript that just happens to exploit
a bug in memory safety like it
causes javascript to underflow a
reference counter and the script still
has its hands
on that object and it's trying to call a
method on it and there's some kind of
lookup function table in the object
but you've managed to stuff the heap
with strings that
forged their own lookalike for the
function
table you can call some other code and
this was a problem
right away so security you know
javascript upped the ante java had this
problem too but in its own vm
and it just was you know a separate
headache for
sun to worry about we had this problem
in netscape right away so netscape 2
came out
after my 10 days and after these you
know follow-on work to embed
javascript better in the browser and to
add garbage or collection through
reference counting really
i'd call it reference counting and get
it shipped
we had a bunch of dot releases where we
fixed security bugs like maniacs
but what is the thing you're you know
when you sit back
on a porch and just look out into the
sunset what are you most proud of from
those 10 days
i think the first class function shines
i think especially since java didn't
have it and it was
somewhat unusual scheme made it
at the end in somehow day in spirit i
mean people complain because scheme has
you know minimalism it has you know six
or seven special forms it has
hygienic macros it has call cc it has
sort of
a beautiful uh complete um
set of forms to make the lambda calculus
pleasant to use in in practice
um and javascript is you know kind of
a multi-paradigm or shambolic
you